viviamo in un mondo accelerato pieno di
innovazione di cambiamenti in cui sembra
che il paradigma vincente sia quella
delle big tech delle grandi imprese
internazionali oppure delle startup che
diventano unicorno la realtà economica
in realtà non è fatta solo di questo
tipologia di imprese se andiamo a vedere
i numeri in unione europea ad esempio
dei venti e passa milioni di imprese
circa il 90 9,1 per cento sono piccole e
medie imprese
eppure contano per quasi due terzi
dell'occupazione nel nostro paese poi
l'italia il 90
5,05 per cento delle imprese sono
addirittura micro cioè hanno meno di 10
addetti eppure danno un contributo
fondamentale anche all'export quello del
nostro made in italy
voglio raccontarvi alcune storie che
riguardano proprio un gruppo piccolo di
microimprese delle botteghe di
artigianato artistico che abitano in una
città
intendo parlarvi dei liutai di cremona
che producono viole violini violoncelli
e gli sport e del tutto il mondo è un
tema che mi è cara mia è molto caro per
almeno due motivi il primo è che insegno
studio strategia aziendale
imprenditorialità quindi mi occupo delle
piccole e medie imprese un po in tutto
il mondo e queste imprese sono
particolarmente interessanti
il secondo motivo è che sono cremonese
quindi sto parlando della mia città ho
scoperto tardi l'esistenza dei liutai da
piccolo quando girava il mondo e
qualcuno mi chiedeva da dove vieni
rispondevo da una città vicino a milano
che nero che cremona non la conoscesse
proprio nessuno può invece da grande da
professore universitario da ricercatore
sono orgoglioso di rispondere vengo da
cremona perché ho scoperto che cremona e
conosciuto davvero in tutto il mondo
merito di un nostro concittadino nato
300 70 anni fa il suo nome è antonio
stradivari
parliamo dunque dei liutai di questa
realtà quanti sono innanzitutto vediamo
un confine una descrizione di questa
realtà a cremona in una città di 72.000
abitanti vivono e operano circa
185 botteghe 183 botte e che producono a
mano strumenti venduti in tutto il mondo
se poi aggiungiamo anche gli artigiani
che fanno le custodie con gli archetti
siamo circa 200 imprese
esportano in giappone in cina in asia
negli stati uniti da cosa deriva questo
successo incredibile di questo gruppo di
piccoli artisti con uno spirito
imprenditoriale fortissimo la loro
storia può essere racchiusa attorno a
quattro parole chiave
la prima è tradizione la seconda è
marchio brehme la terza e territorio e
la quarta e innovazione
la prima parola tradizione il legame tra
la produzione di violini e la città di
cremona affonda le sue radici in secoli
fa per la precisione nel cinquecento in
pieno rinascimento a cremone operava un
liutaio andrea macrì e poi i suoi figli
e la sua discendenza è colui che ha
sistematizzato la forma del violino
possiamo quasi considerarlo l'inventore
del violino
dopo di lui altri due famiglie
importanti la famiglia guarneri con
andremo arner i suoi discendenti in
particolar modo giuseppe guarneri detto
del gesù è appunto la famiglia di
antonio stradivari antonio stradivari
nasce nella metà del seicento opera fino
al agli anni trenta del settecento
perché vive addirittura a 93 anni
produce circa 1.100 strumenti di cui 600
700 sono ancora in circolazione anche se
la metà di questi sono chiusi nei musei
o nei caveau delle banche perché stiamo
parlando di strumenti che oggi valgono
milioni o decine di milioni di euro
dopo il guarneri dopo gli stradivari
abbiamo avuto ancora altri importanti
liutai era cremona bergonzi ceruti ma in
particolar modo il settecento l'anno
d'oro secolo d'oro scusate dei liutai
cremonesi aiuta di allora tra cui
antonio stradivari erano un po come gli
start upper di oggi erano dei veri
imprenditori
organizzati puntigliosi avevano
collaboratori aveva una capacità diremmo
oggi di mark finché di comunicazione
elevatissima avevano cliente in tutta
europa sovrani principi cortigiani
musicisti sapevano variare il prodotto a
seconda delle esigenze dei loro clienti
e dell'andamento della musica con una
lungimiranza e una capacità anche di
innovare veramente note ma è così per
circa due secoli e mezzo di generazione
in generazione il know how il sapere
questo patrimonio incredibile conoscenza
è stato tramandato una città di cremona
fino ad arrivare alla fine
dell'ottocento in cui questo spirito
imprenditoriale questa creatività questa
capacità artistica sembra essersi
esaurita tra la fine dell'ottocento e
l'inizio del novecento nella città di
cremona rimanevano solo modesti
artigiani costruttori di strumenti nulla
a che vedere con la grandezza la
capacità dei capolavori e dei nomi come
antonio stradivari
quindi sembrava finita questa storia
nel 1930 succede qualcosa
e da lì un po come l'araba fenice la
liuteria cremonese ripartirà nel 1930
unità il bolognese di nome giuseppe
fiorini donò alla città di cremona
i reperti stradivariano cioè esattamente
gli attrezzi disegni le forme il canton
yo stradivari e suoi figli utilizzavano
la bottega tra il seicento e settecento
un patrimonio di conoscenza incredibile
nel 1937 ricorre il bicentenario della
morte di stradivari si riattiva la città
tanto che nel 1938 viene costituita
fondata una scuola internazionale di
liuteria dedicata proprio ad antonio
stradivari la seconda guerra mondiale
interrompe questo ciclo di subito dopo
però è frutto ancora di un liutaio che
viene da fuori questa volta di origine
romane ma di fatto newyorkese americano
simone sacconi che si trasferisce
cremona inizia a studiare i reperti
stradivaria ne capisce la portata di
quegli attrezzi di quei documenti per
far ripartire la conoscenza scrive un
libro i segreti di estrattiva che viene
tradotto in tante lingue e fatti giro
per il mondo
quel libro il lavoro di sacconi la
presenza anche della scuola di liuteria
riattiva improvvisamente negli anni
sessanta una nuova generazione di liutai
da prima cremonese poi italiani poi
internazionale perché negli anni 70 80
aprono a cremona una bottega ed allora
danno vita a quel apparato produttivo
unico al mondo i violini di altissima
qualità e alto prezzo che noi conosciamo
come leader in questo momento una
produzione di strumenti musicali
la seconda parola di cui vi voglio
parlare insieme a tradizioni è invece
marchio sì perché ho citato i nomi di
grandi liutai amati guarneri stradivari
ecco antonio stradivari per esempio è un
brand fortissimo lo conoscono tutti nel
mondo ed è sinonimo di maestria di
capolavori assoluti di una capacità
qualitative di performance incredibile
bene quel marchio antonio stradivari ha
un valore economico molto alto anche per
i nostri aiuta i contemporanei perché è
sinonimo di qualità operare oggi nel
2021 nel nome di antonio stradivari
significa poter avere agli occhi dei
clienti contemporanei una garanzia di
qualità di eccellenza di maestria che
viene associata alla reputazione di
questo maestro
ma non è l'unico marchio che entra nel
gioco e nella storia dei nostri aiutare
l'altro brand importantissimo e cremona
sì perché cremona compariva fine gli
strumenti di amati di guarneri
l'etichetta interna che è un po il brand
e dei prodotti moderni diceva maestro
tal dei tali fecit in cremone anno
domini e ancora oggi i maestri liutai in
verità è tutto il mondo quando firmano
il loro strumento mettono il loro nome e
la città da cui proviene in cui è stato
realizzato ora made in cremona ha un
valore ancora superiore al made in italy
per gli
per gli appassionati e gli esperti di
liuteria ed è per questo ad esempio che
oltre al brand stradivari il brand
cremona è oggetto di utilizzo ed è
oggetto anche di riflessioni su come
promuovere come tutelarlo come difendere
un marchio di origine
un po come nell'alimentare le dop le igp
le denominazioni di origine controllata
e garantita quindi i marchi la terza
parola che sta alla base del successo
dei nostri in italia territorio
sì perché fare violini a cremona o
violoncelli e viole produrli e
trasferirla in tutto il mondo non è come
farlo in un'altra zona è un'altra
località liutai anche molto bravi ci
sono un po in tutto il mondo in europa
negli stati uniti adesso anche in asia
ma operare qui a cremona vuol dire
appartenere a un sistema territoriale
respirare un'atmosfera del violino e
della musica che non è presente nessun
altra parte del mondo
e per questo che molti liutai stranieri
vengono a studiare cremona e poi
rimangono qui ad aprire le loro botteghe
e vivono qui c'è direbbero i latini un
genius loci qualcosa a uno spiritello
che abita questo è che non è casuale e
non è mito è un sistema territoriale un
sistema cognitivo che produce conoscenza
e che è fatto di tanti attori
innanzitutto abbiamo una scuola
superiore scuole istituto superiore di
formazione che si chiama antonio
stradivari
non a caso poi abbiamo la fondazione
antonio stradivari fondazione antonio
stradivari gestisce questo bellissimo
museo in cui siamo in questo momento a
fare le riprese il museo del violino
l'unico esistente al mondo ma gestisce
anche il concorso internazionale
triennali di liuteria uno dei più
prestigiosi premi a livello mondiale a
cui si iscrivono aiutai di tutto il
mondo per essere giudicati nella loro
capacità di lavoro infine ha creato
anche friends of stradivari un network
tra tutti i proprietari di stradivari e
di violini storici del mondo che mette
insieme qui a cremona miliardari o anche
semplici appassionati musicisti
provenienti da tutto il mondo che hanno
proprietari o in uso
violino stradivari c'è anche un
consorzio creato da una cinquantina di
aiutai tra i 180 che abitano a cremona
che lavora insieme e anche questo si
chiama guarda caso consorzio scrittorio
stradivari poi c'è cremona musica
cremona musica è una manifestazione
fieristica annuale è la più importante a
livello mondiale per gli strumenti
musicali di altissima qualità e ha sede
a cremona ma non è finito nel lago cioè
la camera di commercio ad esempio che da
decenni sostiene lo sviluppo di aiutare
e con lei le associazioni artigiane e ci
sono addirittura tre università che
hanno sede a cremona l'università
cattolica il politecnico di militari di
milano l'università degli studi di pavia
che sono presenti con propri centri di
ricerca in alcuni casi anche dei
percorsi di laurea che si occupano della
liuteria della musica ma ne parleremo
tra un attimo e infine la cabina di
regia di tutto questo è in mano al
comune di cremona che ha costituito il
distretto della liuteria che ha proprio
la la missione di tutelare e sviluppare
questo distretto locale
la quarta parola dopo innovazione dopo
tradizione marchi territorio e
innovazione e mi ha raccontato come agli
uteri a quella contemporanea cremonese
come l'araba fenice è risorta dalle sue
ceneri dopo la seconda guerra mondiale
ma in quel mondo che sta cambiando che
vi ho citato all'inizio non c'è il
rischio che in qualche modo questa
seconda liuteria posso ancora una volta
a cedere il passo perché la competizione
forte il sapere si produce di tanti modi
diversi quindi riusciranno i nostri
aiuta i cremonesi a mantenere il
vantaggio competitivo la risposta è sì
se non si sederanno sugli allori e loro
lo sanno fare innovazione e cambiare lo
stesso stradivari nel corso della sua
lunga vita ha modificato tanti aspetti
del violino perché la musica evolveva la
tensione delle corde l'inclinazione
della pastiera richiedeva del manico
richiedeva alcune modifiche le bombature
né fuori
e anche per questo motivo che in questo
bellissimo museo del violino sono
insediati due laboratori scientifici il
primo si chiama laboratorio di acustica
musicale del politecnico di milano
studia le capacità fisiche acustiche dei
materiali degli strumenti musicali ed è
finalizzato proprio a dare una mano
aiuta i cremonesi ad avere una
consapevolezza un rispetto a come la
tecnologia può aiutare anche lo
strumento moderno l'altro è il
laboratorio arvedi di analisi
diagnostiche non invasive
dell'università di pavia è dedicato
invece all'analisi alla conservazione e
al restauro degli strumenti antichi e
anche noi come università cattolica ci
diamo da fare perché abbiamo ricerche in
corso ad esempio sui processi di
digitalizzazione nel tie delle botteghe
da un punto di vista dell'e commerce da
un punto di vista dell'utilizzo della
realtà aumentata in realtà virtuale per
far vedere i loro strumenti per gestire
le relazioni con clienti in tutto il
mondo perché faccio un esempio di
innovazione
quest'anno la rivista next one nation
saliti ciclone forsa pubblicato un paper
un lavoro di ricerca ha fatto proprio
dai ricercatori del politecnico in paper
si intitola
data driven approach to fail magic un
approccio basato sui big data per la
produzione dei violini e si spiega come
le tavole armoniche quelle che
costituiscono poi la cassa del violino
possono essere analizzate con sistemi di
intelligenza artificiale reti neurali
che attraverso la modellizzazione
matematica il liutaio può in teoria
decidere qual è la forma gli spessori
migliori per ottenere un certo tipo di
suono piuttosto che un'altra dunque
abbiamo detto tradizione marmi
territorio innovazione
ma andrà sempre avanti così che cosa ci
racconta questa storia ci racconta di
una storia che è sempre in tensione tra
innovazione e tradizione
una tensione tra un passato glorioso e
un presente di successo in un futuro che
però è aperto e che richiede massima
attenzione
l'importante è non sedersi sugli allori
e allora per esempio anche per il tie
cremonese per il sistema territoriale
porsi seriamente il problema del
costruire il futuro in maniera
innovativa
e la via per il successo anche futuro e
ci aiuta in questo a capire il senso
usaf mahler conoscete compositore
direttore d'orchestra austriaco che in
quanto a innovazione della musica
semente rivela che una volta ebbe a dire
la tradizione e custodire il fuoco non
adorare le cene devo dire non si può
stare fermi bisogna riattivare la fiamma
che effettivamente cillo e quello che i
liutai e sistema cremonese sicuramente
saprà fare nei fin dei conti forse è
quello che tutto il made in italy deve
fare o forse anche il nostro sistema
paese